mr rabb really good to see this morning
uh house conference been for you
well good morning look i i think uh it's
been great to get everyone back together
in person our message is that we're
building back better uh from this awful
pan they're making the governments
getting on with the job whether it's the
support for workers and employers
through the pandemic as we come out the
other side through to the reform of
social care and dealing with the nhs
backlog and the court's backlog which is
obviously dear to my heart given the
justice brief
indeed and we will move on to that in
just a second but you and i have spoken
an awful lot frankly over the past year
and a half largely however that has been
when you were occupying a slightly
different job that that of foreign
secretary many people saw your move to
justice as a as a demotion was there any
part of you aggrieved at the decision
that the prime minister made
no
look
my job is to serve the government and
ultimately the country the prime
minister
has asked me to go back to the ministry
of justice where i've served twice
before um i've been given the role of
deputy prime minister which i'm honored
to to do and frankly what i care about
most is delivering on the court's
backlog given the aftermath of the
appalling case of sarah everard what
more we can do to make women feel safer
and confident in the criminal justice
system
and rehabilitating offenders more
generally so to be honest with you all
of the media if you like side
show i just um i tend to cut through and
just get on with the job
and it is a pretty tremendous job that
you have in front of you what one has to
say
tackling the problems with the courts
tackling the problems with the prisons i
just want to pick up on something though
that we heard from both uh kept malthus
the policing minister and and indeed the
prime minister yesterday a degree of
pushback on the idea that the
significant cuts that there have been
and you will concede there have been
significant cuts to ministry of justice
budget to the cps to frontline policing
to activity in the courts that those
cuts have had not had any effect on the
conviction rates
so first of all let's get the numbers
very straight since 2010 between 2010
and 2016 the moj budget the spend was
reduced by roughly a quarter that was us
dealing with the aftermath of the
economic crisis and the mess that the
labour party made of it from 2017 to
current day we increased the budget by
nine percent but it's not just about
money so for example if you look at uh
one of the measures that we're taking to
come through uh the backlog and in the
civil law system things like probate and
divorce we've had tremendous success in
a driving efficiency and better service
for those that use the justice system is
digitization and technology so yes
investment is important it's increased
by nine percent in my department since
2017 but there are other things it's the
way we do things that matter as well and
i think that's true for the experience
of whether it's witnesses victims or the
wider public of what they see and feel
of the criminal justice system
but just to pick you up in a specific
sentence construction you just used
there that it is not just to do with the
money i would agree with that it just
seems though that kit malt house
yesterday the prime minister yesterday
suggested that it's nothing to do with
the cut in the budgets that we've seen
at the mlg
well we've had an increase in the budget
by nine percent since 2017 so i'm making
the point that of course uh it's
important to invest in the right areas
but you've got to retain a responsible
approach to the public finances all
together and what i'm also saying and
that i've got the advantage as you said
neil coming back to the moj um i was
courts minister in 2018.
let me give you three example gps
tagging
sobriety tags and virtual
giving of evidence or pre-recorded
giving evidence for vulnerable victims
in those three areas we've seen
game-changing shifts in the way the
courts and the justice system approach
matters and that is probably the most
exciting one of the most exciting things
and opportunities for me in terms of the
next two years because those things can
not only drive efficiencies and
allow us to invest in different ways
more effectively without just relying on
extra dollops of cash but also will
deliver for as i said vulnerable victims
witnesses and the average member of the
citizen that has very little and pretty
rare contact with the justice system a
much better service
just in terms of the of the sarah
everard situation and the inquiry that
is that has been set up why has that not
been put on a statutory footing as it is
the inquiry not in the statutory footing
cannot compel witnesses to attend cannot
compel witnesses to give testimony given
that one of the central accusations
against the met is that they close ranks
when one of their own is targeted surely
this needs to be put on a statutory
footing
i think what people want is a uh us to
get cracking on this
as soon as possible and to get to the
truth the inquiry that the home system
it'll work um and i think there by the
way let's be clear this needs to be
looked at robustly vigorously without
fear or favor but i do also think that
the police as a whole and the vast
majority of uh of officers are appalled
by this and want to get those answers
too and therefore
describe this is dealing with it
robustly if we cannot compel people to
give testimony
we're not going to have a problem uh
getting uh to the truth of this because
i'm telling you i think the vast
majority of officers will want to
proactively support this but there are
two elements
the vast majority of officers will want
to contribute but of course you're not
suggesting that the bad eggs in the
metropolitan police are anything other
than a small minorities the small
minority we're talking about here
absolutely which is why
the inquiry and the review that the home
secretary announced will do first of all
find out why and how wayne cousins could
have risen through the ranks and
things like the flashing incidents and
all the other
if you like red flags that were going up
why they weren't taken more seriously
secondly it will look at systemic issues
cultural issues
within the police and i'm confident we
will get to the bottom of this and as
justice secretary we will have a we're
already through the uh the the review of
uh rape uh cases and our violence
against women and girls strategy we're
going to look root and branch at
everything from
i'm talking about the experiences of
female
victims and everything from the time it
takes to examine a mobile phone in
evidence right the way through to and
we're already doing this protecting
vulnerable uh victims giving evidence in
court so you don't find that on top of
the appalling ordeal physical and mental
trauma they've been through that the
justice system isn't compounding that
with the way that they're treated so we
will look at everything from top to
bottom
and i
look i've said it's my number one
priority to make sure women feel
confident in the justice system and
confident in being able to walk the
streets without having to look over
their shoulder in fear
let's talk about the the prime minister
the man to whom you are of course in
your new role as deputy prime minister
number two uh what are we to to make of
the the emphasis this week on wage
growth on wage growth as being
not the be all and end all but certainly
an overwhelming priority for the prime
minister
is no one in government concerned
that wage at wage growth goes hand in
hand with an increase in inflation
well look there's clearly as we go
through the pandemic this issue of um
inflation but uh the forecasts show that
uh after the this year it comes back
down and of course the bank of england
has a mandate to target two percent but
the paradigm shift we're seeing in the
economy something that was much
discussed during the brexit referendum
but as part of as we come through the
pandemic the prime minister's overriding
priorities we've got a great record on
bringing down unemployment raising
employment the number of vacancies uh
being advertised for those who are
coming off uh benefits or who have been
uh furloughed is is remarkable two
million uh more jobs than were expected
but we also need to make sure people can
afford to live uh can afford to pay the
bills and
that's why with real wages rising so
over and above inflation on the latest
quarterly figures uh six and a half
sorry six percent above inflation
compared to the same time last year with
the national living wage extended uh
saving the average worker eligible four
thousand pounds a year it is critically
important and what we are also saying is
we want our vision is a high employment
high skilled high-wage economy but not
and it's certainly going to take a lot
longer than for example a decision the
prime minister could make like that and
not take 20 pounds a week off of some of
the poorest working family 20 pounds a
week of some of the poorest working
families in the country i mean the
statistics on this are really weird we
get ian duncan smith in the program
later on and he will rail against this
and the reason is 4.4 million households
with 3.5 million children will see their
incomes drop by more than a thousand
pounds according to the resolution
foundation why are we doing this
so first of all we carried uh and
supported the government supported 40
million people uh through furlough
through this pandemic we extended
universal credit and that was always
intended to be temporary i've explained
to you the national living wage we've
also uh made sure that we through
the extension the purse allowance
personal allowance for income tax saving
every worker 1200 pounds
a year but just specifically on uc we
also announced to get people off that
risk of long-term unemployment and
benefit reliance including uc a two
billion pound
kickstart package just one of the uh the
400 billion pound measures uh that the
chancellor has introduced so we are
saying that of course the welfare system
is there for them those most in need but
what we want to do and there's two pound
billion pounds going into the kickstart
scheme it's been extended is supporting
people off benefits into work that must
be right over the longer term
these aren't back of a [ __ ] packet
calculations i mean the legatum
institute says that the extra support
has protected 840 000 people from
poverty in the second quarter of this
year including and again i know it's a
motive to mention but 290 000 children i
mean what is your message directly to
those who will be moved into poverty as
a result of the ending of the 20 pounds
a week uplift today
well of course the emergency support we
provided was because of the pandemic as
we come through the pandemic with uh
youth unemployment going down employment
going up we need to transition we don't
want to see people reliant on the
welfare trap we want to where it's
possible and i know for not everyone if
someone's got a disability that it'll
different set of circumstances there's
targeted support there but where it's
possible the right thing to do as we
come through this pandemic we've got uh
employment rising vacancies and a record
high university are either in work or
looking for work though mr rabbi don't
understand this argument
and and and that's why with wages
through the national living wage with
the personal income tax with uh not
relying on the cheap drug of skilled of
unskilled labor from abroad
our overall driving force of the
economic plan is to see wages go up and
they have gone up and i just cited to
you the figures and the the annualized
figures for the latest quarter that real
wages over inflation have increased by
six percent we've got to start this way
overlaying four percent in terms of uh
in terms of wage growth which is pretty
much in line with inflation isn't it no
no no no no i i checked this morning
before i came on yours
the latest ons explanation and it says
six percent uh if you strip out bonuses
uh and those that get an uplift it's
four and a half percent those are the
figures the latest figures that the ons
uh have provided but look the bottom
line is the government wants uh to
increase and promote the job creation
that we've seen that's relying on the
entrepreneurs we want to support the
most vulnerable but we've also got to
transition people into higher paid
jobs that is the sustainable long-term
solution and i don't see any other party
with a credible alternative
mr rob we will be speaking again in the
very near future i'm sure good to see
you this morning thanks being with us
thank you